welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid so in a previous video I had some
trouble with my teleporter if you
haven't seen it there's a link in the
description feel free to head on over
there after this video don't worry I
fixed it so we shouldn't have any
problems like that for a while some of
you might be wondering though can I have
one no how come scientists haven't
invented this yet well I invented it and
I'm not sharing but there are very good
reasons why no one else has made this
discovery when any scientists get
remotely close to the science resembling
the kind behind a teleporter they go
full-on crazy and end up in here where I
have access to their brain power where
was I all right
every tangible thing is made of
chemicals which are made of molecules
which are made of atoms which are made
of subatomic particles will you get the
idea there is a lot more to the
existence of something than appearances
suggests even more so for living things
with all standard methods of
teleportation you'll be taken apart at
the microscopic level and that's the
easy part
the hard part is putting you back
together at your destination the first
machine we'll need to take some kind of
record of where all your stuff was and
what it was all doing that record is
then used by the second machine with
enough control over matter to reassemble
you scientists that don't go crazy run
into several problems with this first
the best advices we have for detecting
matter are mass spectrometers and the
best for controlling matter our particle
accelerators the more precise you want
these devices to be the bigger they have
to be this pose is not only practical
issues but also financial ones though
this isn't anything Tony Stark couldn't
overcome shut up Milton second stuff at
the microscopic level is just weird we
have this pesky little rule in quantum
physics called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle which basically
says we can never know exactly where
something is or exactly what something
is doing and the more we know one of
those things the less we know the other
this isn't a technological limitation
it's a physical one that the universe
imposes on itself microscopic particles
are inherently random and inexact going
crazy yet we'll stop it I don't want to
see you in here tomorrow sorry that
might have been a little rude
if you want to admit yourself tomorrow
you can that's cool if you think about
it inherit randomness isn't that
unbelievable try to remember how many
random songs have just popped into your
head for no reason speaking of random
things popping into heads what about all
the philosophical issues with
teleportation do you die in the
teleportation process is the person that
arrives on the other end
actually you were cloned with all your
memories what happens if the second
machine creates you but the first one
doesn't take you apart either now two of
you do we have to kill one now if so
which one ah I'm gonna let you in on a
little secret
no no not you stop listening yeah yeah
you my teleporter doesn't actually take
me apart I simply occupy all space
simultaneously for less than 10 to the
minus 43 seconds what does that number
even mean that's a tenth of a millionth
of a trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second or point zero
zero zero zero what that's forty two
zeros and a one how do you do that
that's for me to know and you to never
find out so if you had a teleporter
would you use it for good or evil let us
know in the comments with details and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy uh-oh
you
yeah